one god. It is only revealed to
me. Meaning, with regards to
this issue. Ascribe to Allah
Children, ascribe to Allah
equals, ascribe to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, those that
they worship along with Allah.
Yet here he says, it is only
revealed to me that your God is
but one God, the one worthy of
worship is Allah alone without
any partner subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He says, so will you be
Muslims in submission to him?
Muslim, is
It is a noun that is derived
from the verb
Which is a past tense three
letter verb to mean.
Submission.
and
Islam was defined to us by
the prophet
When
he was asked, what is
Islam by Jibreel? He said, the
testimony that none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah,
Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah, the establishment of
prayer, giving zakah, fasting
Ramadan, and making pilgrimage
to the house of Allah if you
have the ability to do so.
These are known as the five
pillars of Islam. and
is a definition
something by its most prominent
elements. This is a definition
of something by its most
prominent elements. Meaning
that the most prominent,
fundamentals of Islam are in
these five pillars. This is why
they're referred to as pillars
of Islam. Otherwise, Islam is
broader than that in the
general sense. More things are
involved. The prophet said in
another in another narration
says, Islam has been built upon
five pillars. Islam has been
built upon five pillars. So,
here these five pillars in this
narration are articulated to be
different than Islam as a
whole. They are part of Islam
but they are not all of Islam.
And this is common in the words
of the prophet common in
everyone's words. If you want
to articulate the immensity of
something, it is correct two,
define it by some of its most
fundamental parts. So, for
example, if you say, the
prophet said, Hajj is Arafa.
Hajj is Arafa. Meaning,
standing on the mountain of
Arafaj Hajj. Does this mean
that if a person only does
Arafa does nothing else that
their Hajj would be valid? Of
course, not. Their Hajj would
be invalid according to the
consensus of all of the
Muslims. What is meant here is
to articulate the immensity of
the of the issue of standing on
the mountain of Arafa. This is
crucial and if you miss this
pillar, you've missed
basically, essentially, you've
missed Hajj. Another thing is
as the prophet
mentions that Allah said, I
have divided prayer between
myself and my servant. And then
he goes on to mention
all of prayer. No. Sura is a
very crucial part. It is a
kingpin of prayer but it
doesn't mean that it is all of
prayer, right? If a person just
recites then their prayer is is
invalid according to the
consensus of all of the
Muslims. The point here is that
the prophet was asked, what is
Islam? And so he defined it by
its most prominent, by its most
promin
pillars. Likewise, if we were
to look, what is Islam? Let us
define Islam in its entirety.
We want a comprehensive
definition of Islam. What is
it? The comprehensive
definition of Islam.
That is the comprehensive
definition of the Islam of all
of mankind, of all of the
prophets and the messengers.
This is the Islam that they
brought to humanity. It is
summed up in three things. This
definition is as follows. Islam
is
submission to Allah
Bethel Heat that a person
worship Allah and Allah alone.
Number two,
is adherence to Allah's
command.
adherence to a law and
obedience. What's meant by that
is that a person have a
general, holistic,
general, holistic attitude of
adherence. Doesn't mean that
the person will adhere to every
single thing in the legislation
of Islam. Islam is very big.
It's very broad. We're all
going to eventually fall short.
What's meant is that a person
has the general attitude of
adherence. but for a person
says, yes, I'm Muslim but I
don't feel you know, I
have to do any of these things
that
obviously can this person can
never be Muslim with this
attitude Amazon valid.
Likewise, a person accepts
Islam
but has no
in their behavior, in their
action, in their attitude, in
any facet of their life
whatsoever after they accepted
Islam from before they accepted
Islam. They are exactly the
same thing. Nothing has
changed. This happens often.
When people become Muslim for
certain reasons. you know.
People may become Muslim to get
married to someone or they may
become Muslim. So they come in
and just you know a lunge,
leave. It it goes no further
than that. This Islam cannot be
valid. Us, there has to be some
element of adherence, right?
Even if it's a weak element of
adherence. If it's weak, even
if it's so weak that some of
the pillars of Islam are not
fulfilled. This Islam will
still be valid. However,
complete disregard for
adherence cannot be cannot be
this person cannot be a Muslim
and this is referred to in the
books of the as, excuse me, as,
or is referred to as and that
is that a person says yes, we
believe you're a prophet,
you're a messenger, but that
doesn't really change the price
tea in China. You know, that's
it. It it doesn't change
anything. Yes, we believe it.
Yes, we believe that this is a
prophet, a messenger, but it's
not going to have any bearing
on my life. This is a type of
and it's a type of kufar that
was present in the time of the
prophet Some people didn't
believe that he was a messenger
while others did believe and
they had they they relented and
said, yes, we believe that he
is a messenger but that doesn't
apply to us. It's not it's not
going to interfere at all with
our business. This is a type of
kufar. This is called the point
here is that The first element
is submission to Allah with
Tawheed. The second, adherence
to Allah and obedience. The
third is disassociation. Sheikh
and its people. Sheikh and its
people. What do we mean by
that? What's meant here is
disassociation from Schick and
its people. Meaning that a
person completely reject Jeric
and completely reject its
people. Now, this doesn't mean
that a person rejects its
people naturally which rejects
its people.
legislatively and there's a
difference Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says about the prophet
to not guide those whom you
love. and guide all those whom
you love. This verse was
revealed regarding Abu Talib.
Prophet's uncle. Died as a as a
as a mushlik.
out. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
affirmed parently in this verse
that the prophet had love for
him, correct? So, he loved him.
But he did not love him in a
legislative sense. He loved him
in a in a natural sense. It's
a person who has a mother
that's a non Muslim, a father,
a guy, a neighbor that you know
moses lawn and doesn't throw
grass clippings in your
driveway. Whatever. this is
natural. You naturally like
this person, right? But you
don't legislatively this
person. You don't them and
gain nearness to Allah by
liking them. That's a different
thing. That's a legislative
love, right? That is only
befitting for the Muslims. So,
I love all Muslims, those of
them who I've met, and those of
them whom I haven't met, right?
That's legislative of love
contrary to you know, if a
person has a Christian mother
to say, I love all Christians
no matter who they are, those
of them who I've met and those
who I haven't met. No, this is
this is a legislative love,
right? We are loving based on
on the legislation of Islam.
This is a strictly a Muslim
emotion. This is a this is
something that is is for the
Muslims towards each other.
It's something specific about
Islam. However natural love. A
person has natural love. A
person may love a Muslim
legislatively and naturally
dislike that same person,
right? This is possible.
Naturally, naturally, this
person's, you know, this
person's personality in mind,
they clash. I just really don't
him but legislatively as
my Muslim brother, no, I love
my Muslim brother and he's owed
obligations and rights and so
forth, right? but when we say
disassociation from shirk and
its people, it's meant in the
legislative sense, right? Not
in the natural sense. There's
no clash there between the two.
No, clash between the two.
says subhanahu wa ta'ala
but if they turn away, then say
I have announced to all of you
equally and I know not whether
near or far is that which you
are promised. That which you
are promised, meaning, of the
things that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala warned them of. If you
disbelieve in Allah, if you
disbelieve in the prophet
tragedy will befall you. They
are saying, when is this
alleged punishment going to
come? He says, Subhanahu wa
ta'ala that the prophet should
reply to this and say, and I
know not whether near or far is
that which you are promised.
Indeed, he, Allah, knows what
is declared of speech. And he
knows what you conceal. And I
know not perhaps this
punishment a trial for you.
Meaning, it being delayed
Posponement of this punishment.
As a trial for you and
enjoyment for a time. The
prophet has said, my lord,
judge between us in truth. And
our lord is the most merciful
and the one whose help is
sought against that which you
describe. which you describe
meaning there lies, their
fabrications, their arguments,
their
and so forth, their disbelief
that they face the prophet
with. With that, we have
concluded Surat Al Ambia.
[Arabic recitation]